good morning everyone
can you see my screen yes we can see
your screen columnary you can go ahead
okay great i'm going to talk about my
project that is
entitled classification of triple
negative breast cancer cell lines by
gene expression analysis
of strand membrane proteins using
machine learning algorithms
my name is carlo marie major alpena just
to talk a little about myself i'm from
keretaron city in mexico and i'm a phd
student from the program of
biotechnology
at technological monterey and actually
my phd is about the development of
devices for the diagnosis of triple
negative breast cancer so
i have interest in finding
new biomarkers that could improve the
analysis and the diagnosis of this this
type of disease
just in order to have some context about
the triple negative breast cancer it
represents
from 10 to 20 percent of breast cancer
however it is highly heterogeneous so
it's difficult to
diagnose there are several subtypes
and also a
well the main characteristic of this
type of disease
is that these breast cancers they they
have negative
response to estrogen receptors
progesterone receptors and also
epidermal growth factor receptor as a
result
the the hormonal and the immune
therapies are not very effective and
also a common is commonly an
an aggressive type of disease so the
treatment is difficult
and early diagnosis is important
in order to have a positive outcome
when you are diagnosed with this disease
so and in order to
to find new biomarkers well
the type of biomarkers i'm interested on
are the
membrane biomarkers because well they
can be used for
for prognostics to know the prognosis
and also
to monitor the development of different
type of cancer
they also are critical in in they play
an important role
in in cellular structure and function
and also
in the proliferation of cancerous cells
and and also they
they are important as a
drug target in the pharmaceutical
perspective
so for this reason i decided
to generate a question and it says
it is possible to classify breast cancer
cells by gene expression analysis of
strong membrane proteins
using machine learning and well the
hypothesis is that these breast cancers
cell lines can be classified in the
molecular
subtypes using the expression of these
transmembrane proteins and also
implementing
the machine learning algorithms and the
methodology
consists in when one in an approach the
first approach
is it involves the selection
of transmembrane proteins
the annotation of the genes that are
present in a data set
then performing some machine learning
analysis
using these genes that are selected
and then validating these
all these genes with with another data
set in order to see
if the machine learning and the genes
are performing
in a proper manner and for the second
approach
in that in this approach the idea is to
select
genes that are useful for the
classification of breast cancer but
that are not necessarily
transmembrane genes and then perform the
the same type of machine learning
analysis and validation
in order to get at the end a list of
transmembrane genes that are common
with both approaches and which could be
analyzed as candidates
for for diagnosis
and the the two
data sets that i that i used in this
project
and the first one is is based in the
article of modeling precision uh
treatment of breast cancer
and the second one is is a recent data
set
that was used for the external
validation and it was
a it was from a professor from harvard
medical school
here are the the accession numbers
and for the preparation the the first
step was to homogenize the information
present in the data sets
uh i employed a quantity normalization
with a threshold of five then the
annotation and the selection and the
analysis and everything was performed in
the
tower bioinformatics research center
the algorithms and all the analysis
and for the first approach uh
160 genes were annotated as
transmembrane and they were
they were selected and a principal
components analysis was performed
and as you can see there are some of the
groups
are easy to identify according to this
analysis
and well it's important to mention that
the luminal vc and basal bc
they are normal breast cancer they are
not triple negative breast cancer
and the other ones are negative triple
negative breast cancer and non-malignant
then considering that
106 and 6 digits
is a large number i decided to reduce
the number of of genes
and for this i perform a random forest
algorithm
and i used the 10 of the
of the dataset to test the algorithm
with an accuracy
of 83.3 percent and
here is the the criteria
and mean decrease accuracy bigger or
lower
than 2 and lower than -2 and actually i
got
a fourier transmembrane genes according
to this filter selection
and as you can see the groups are
are pretty well separated so
this analysis suggests that a
the posterior analysis could provide
interesting results so
i decided to work with the supervised
machine learning analysis
using dimension for the games and
actually uh the performance
with the first data set wasn't
as as good as expected however well the
number of
samples was reduced so it causes some
difficulties
with the algorithm but during the
validation
using the the second data set
with a larger number of samples to test
well
the the accuracy was was improved and
actually
as you can see is around 90 90 percent
so
i think that these
these genes with the machine learning
algorithm perform well
and then i work in the second approach
and in the second approach i consider
40 14 000 genes
from the first data set and and i also
performed
the feature selection using random
forest
and in that case i used an accuracy
larger than 1.2 or smaller than minus
1.2
because yeah the number were
lower in comparison to the to the other
factor selection and i as a result
i got 133 genes
and as you can see with the principal
component analysis
the groups are pretty well separated
just the the ones of that are breast
cancer
basal breast cancer and luminal breast
cancer are difficult to separate from
the
from the basal and luminal
but in general they look good
so i i performed the supervised machine
learning analysis using the mentioned
genes
and the with the first data set
the the accuracy was was
more was better in that in the
in the previous approach but not as good
as
as i as i expected but during the
uh the external violation with the
second data set
the the accuracy was was good was
over 90 percent so
the all these machine learning
with the genes work pretty well and then
after all these analysis
i decided to check from the the first
approach
using these 40 genes from transmembrane
proteins and and then
try to find which genes are shared by
the two
approaches and according to this
there were two transmembrane genes that
are shared by two approaches
so i go these two candidates that
that could be useful for for future
analysis
so as conclusions well the machine
learning algorithms
that were used were
good for the classification of breast
cancer cell lines
using the gene expression analysis in
both of the approaches
and actually the support vector machine
algorithm provided
better results in comparing to in
comparison to the random forest
also the machine learning algorithms
were validated with with an external
data set
and but more more external validation
with other dataset is is recommended
in order to to know if the
if the results are consistent
and also the the genes
uh well i obtained two genes that
could be interesting for further
analysis
in in the diagnostic area
and also well it's important to mention
that the
well it did the analysis involve only
the gene expression so other aspects of
cancer are not considered
also the accuracy of the machine
learning algorithm can be improved
by modifying the selection procedure and
modifying the cutoff value
during the vector selection and also the
transmembrane proteins
need to be confirmed the expression
doesn't
mean that the protein is present in the
cell
so this
information is necessary and well
i was expecting having more than than
two gene but unfortunately
just to to jeans archer with both
approaches
and that's all
thank you for for your attention
thank you so much calamari for this
excellent presentation
um does anyone have any question for
calamari on this project you can
ask us in the chat box or you can
ask actually have a i actually have a
question
uh calamari could you expand a little
bit more on
uh why you were interested in this
project and what was your previous
experience with bioinformatics and what
have you
learned through this experience
well actually well the
i i had important limitations
with respect to the lab work so i was
trying to
find other ways to complement my my
research that doesn't involve
the use of laboratory facilities and
also well bioinformatically i think this
is a very important tool that could
help in in improving the research
without requiring a
a large amount of of
expenditures with respect of reagents
and materials so
i i had this interest
of implementing bioinformatic approaches
in order to
to make a research more efficient
considering the limitations of resources
and facilities
and for this reason i was interested in
joining the
this research internship and actually i
learned a lot
about the use of of these tools and and
the
i think that the data science
perspective is is very useful
because usually the courses about
bioinformatics
they just uh they just tell you how to
use
some of the databases but you don't see
all of that in
in a in a data science perspective so i
think that
this perspective is very useful and
i i got very interesting results that i
i expect to continue working on
uh one second before we get to those
questions my other question is
so what what are you planning to do with
this project after you're done with this
program
well i would like to to continue with
this project
in order to generate some a paper
so i was thinking that maybe it would be
a good idea to continue
working within the internship or to to
[Music]
to yeah to to enter to the internship
again in order to continue with some
parts of the project
in order to to generate a publication
okay thank you calamari here i have a
question from daido it's asking have you